eerily quiet sometimes when you stand
next to I just peer into his head
sometimes like what's going on in there
if you're a psycho you if you spot
another psycho and there's just like
this there's a fucking movie going on
there that I would love to finance you
almost hospitalized me one times from
laughing so hard like I don't know if
you remember this there's 20 people for
the first show and there's a girl Joe
Rogan that's a 12 with a guy that's a
four I said you're very beautiful and
then she just went and ran with it and
started talking about how her husband
pimps are out know you have fights on if
the 20 bucks you don't know this girl is
beautiful and this retard is just so in
between shows we start talking what's
going on oh my god I had such a great
time I think oh is that stuff true and
she goes yeah go show me the monkey and
she took him the woman's bathroom pull
down her pants the girl had a monkey
that was spotless
she nearly stunk I ate it I offended her
some and then she sucked my dick that
was it I went back to my room and I'm
like Jesus Christ
the cops had to hold him back he's like
I want my $40 that's all he wanted Jesus
you think that's crazy
you're right
[Music]